Welcome to the British Council
Learning Hub
We're here to get you started
and show you where to get help
if you need it
Step 1
The Learning Hub works best
with the most recent
version of Google Chrome
Activities work best on a
Laptop, PC or Mac
But don't worry if your child
uses a table or a phone
They'll still be able to complete
the activities
It's just that the experience
vis better
on a larger screen
Step 2
You will receive a welcome to the
Learning Hub email
inviting you to setup your
child's account
Click on the button or link to
create a password
Oh and keep this email safe
You may need to refer to it again
in the future
Step 3
You will be taken to this page
where we will ask you to create
a password
Choose something memorable
to you and your child
Using a mix of upper and
lowercase letters
Enter the new password twice
and press submit
Step 4
Now let's logon
At the bottom of your welcome
to the Learning Hub email
You will find
the web address for your child's
Learning hub
your child's username
Step 5
Click on the web address
This will take you to your child's
Learning Hub
or either Primary Plus or
Secondary Plus
Whichever course your child
is registered on
Now enter your child's username
and the password you have created
Now you're logged on your child
can access their course modules
Excellent work!
Don't worry if you forget your
password we all do
Just click lost password on the
home page
and follow the instructions
on screen
So this is where you will need to
use your child's username
Copy it from your welcome to
the Learning Hub email
Paste it in the box on the lost
password page
Follow the security check and
reset your password
If you have any problems on the
Learning Hub
We have a special team of people
to help you
Do not worry
and what's more you can write
to them in your own language
they will understand
Simply hit the help button
By the way it's better to
use the help button
Rather than calling or emailing us
Choose what you're having
a problem with
Then type your email address the one
you used to register for the course
Add a brief descriptiom of what's wrong
Don't forget you can write to us in your
own language
Our team will respond in less that
one minute via email
They will reply in English so we
recommend using Google Translate
to translate the text
if you prefer to read in your own
language
So check your email
We will have sent instructions
to solve the problem
If you still need help reply to the email
our support team will give you more help
It's best to join the live classes using
a laptop, PC or Mac
The live classes will be listed here
If your child is joining a live class
It's a good idea to follow this checklist
Ensure your child is in a quiet place
with no distractions
Log on to the Learning Hub a few
minutes in advance
Check your internet connection
Check your tech
We recommend you search for
zoom test
and follow the instructions
on screen
When it's time simply click join
and your child will enter
a waiting room
The teacher will check the identity
of your child using their first name
and the first letter of their
last name
Once the checks are complete the
teacher will start the live class
Remember if you have problems
with this
click the help button and follow
the steps we just covered
To help you log on to the Learning
Hub easily
It's a good idea to bookmark the British
Council Learning Hub website
You do it like this
Click the star on the address bar
then click save
Child protection is so important
to us
To keep everyone safe and to ensure
everyone feels valued and comfortable
We have some golden rules that we
ask all students to follow
Find them in our code
of conduct section
If your child forgets their password
just before class
and you are not available to reset it
a member of staff at the teaching
centre will be able to help
For this reason we recommend
that your child has the British Council
teaching centre phone number to hand
Just in case
And that's it your're all set to go
Watch our other videos
to find out what your child will
be doing on the Learning Hub
Bye!